[Music]
did you with a guy who broke the sound
barrier it just is amazing yesterday for
the first time ever a man plunged 24
miles from the very top of the Earth's
atmosphere now as a result they've
stopped serving liquor on the
International Space Station
swen over
didn't feel a thing when he hit the
bottom I don't know why that thing has
terraces I can see Cleveland anyway this
seems like a bad idea
[Laughter]
presidential election getting close I'm
glad to this this election has been
going on for anything
forty-four years now doesn't it feel
that way
absolutely the Obama campaign is
releasing a new ad showing Americans
whose financial situation has improved
over the past four years new ad yeah
unfortunately the only person who
appears in the ad is Mitt Romney one guy
laughed much longer up there
I think it's Mitt Romney I think he's
there
[Applause]
it's true I'm loaded in a new interview
President Obama said he thinks Mariah
Carey and Nicki Minaj can fix their feud
yeah so it sounds like he's ready for
the second debate he is if that question
should come up no polling across the
country shows the presidential race is
now neck and neck yeah it's an even tie
between not Barack Obama and not Mitt
Romney start happy you know who's in the
news I just read it George W Bush is in
the news yeah that's right a new report
thanks pal a new report that is so I'm
taking your word for it
yes a new report claims that former
president george w bush is now painting
portraits of dogs
apparently his biggest challenge is
trying to get the dogs to play poker sit
around it was a famous Oh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh thanks thank you there's nothing
worse than the long pause and then oh
for God's sake he looks so sad who saw
the endeavor go through Los Angeles
Space Shuttle Endeavor do you see it you
see this thing that was incredible
looking yeah yeah yesterday it took the
Endeavour Space Shuttle 48 hours to
travel twelve miles through downtown Los
Angeles apparently was using the iPhone
5s Apple maps
this is weird many new Starbucks
locations will no longer have tables or
chairs if it's a new Starbucks no tables
or chairs it's a new thing yeah the CEO
of Starbucks said from now on you're
going to have to write your crappy
screenplays at Chipotle
there's always that guy absolutely with
a beret and he's waiting away yeah I
don't know why I'm doing that I'm using
why is he on a turn-of-the-century
typewriter in my scenario he's very
prolific and you're getting he's really
got a lot to say Hulk Hogan is suing
over the release of his sex tape yeah
and guess what so is everyone else I've
never heard of a less appetising sex
tape hole Kogan I gotta see this
[Laughter]
Oh
life comes in huh
I actually saw clips of it actually here
at work when you can get it on your
computer here at work you're always
accessing porn here I thought watched a
lot of porn listen which is a lot of
porn it's true I travel truth just came
out you get a joke about it it's
work-related to see it so suddenly
you're a snooze reporter a director
check it out
forget the middle-east I need to see
Hulk Hogan nude no my favorite part of
it though is when he's done he puts his
bandanna back on not a lot of dudes have
to do that at the end well thanks a lot
baby
[Laughter]